would you rather have your boyfriend get  a notification every time you watched  porn with a description or a  notification where you were at all times  the porn 100 that's easy you can control  that just never watch porn yeah no no  occasions probably would like it I feel  like you'd be turned on you're like oh  she's watching porn you know what I mean  I I just don't know that there's like a  evil one an evil option here fine either  way  I don't want the location like your  foreign choices that you wouldn't be  like embarrassed with it no like oh he's  gonna see this weird [ __ ] tonight I kind  of agree it might turn them on yeah I  feel like you would turn them on